One solution to the shortest
path problem for
weighted undirected graphs is
called Dijkstra's Algorithm.
Let's say we're trying to find
the shortest path from here to here.
We begin by giving all
vertices a distance value.
A distance is the sum of edge weights on
a path between our starting point and
whatever vertex we're on.
At the end of the algorithm,
this distance will be the distance
of the shortest path.
The distance value we
start with is infinity.
This is a placeholder value that will
update whenever we discover a node and
have an actual distance to store.
The node we're starting with
will have a distance of zero.
A common implementation of Dijkstra's
uses a min priority queue,
where the element with
a minimum priority, or
minimum distance in our case,
can be removed efficiently.
We store all of our nodes in
the priority queue and use extract min
to take out the minimum element,
the only one with a distance of zero.
>From our starting node
we have several options.
We will follow each edge and
update the node on the other side with
a distance value,
which is just the weight of the edge.
Now we are faced with a choice.
Which node should we visit?
We'll always pick the node with
the smallest distance value,
which means we run
extract min on the queue.
Because we always pick the node
with the lowest distance,
Dijkstra's is often called
a greedy algorithm.
The philosophy for
this class of algorithms is
pick whatever option looks best at
the moment, hence the name greedy.
We repeat the process visiting all
adjacent nodes that are still in
the queue and updating their distance
values if we can decrease it at all.
We keep going, extracting
the minimum from our queue and
exploring adjacent elements, until
the node we're looking for has been
extracted from the queue or everything
else has a distance of infinity.
Which means the path we're looking for
doesn't exist.
The basic runtime of Dijkstra's is
the number of vertices squared.
Since in the worst case, we visit every
node in the graph once or twice and
every time we visit we need to
search through the queue to find
the minimum element.
There are a lot of optimizations for
Dijkstra's, if the priority queue is
implemented really efficiently,
the runtime looks more like this.
[BLANK_AUDIO]